Tên có lòng tốt là đủ hoa là lo không đủ.
Và đẹp xin ra là một chẻ một câu được lua yên bởi ít nhất là 3 mình mới ra điên đỏ.
Cứa ra điện ngày được một phải thời gian.
Vậy ta lại cho đi sau lấy thí lành quay là em ý được đưa vào một cái tục chức.
Tự thiết, người sau thì cũng khu ở được và sau lấy và đi lặng thả.
Nó nghĩa các bạn này thì bạn ấy chỉ khó, mới mỗi 2 tôi đó.
Vậy bạn ấy hi mình nghĩa, mình làm tất cả cũng được bạn ấy đi choi.
Vậy bạn ấy đi choo, ló cho bạn ấy từng kẻo, từng kua, cũng từng bữa ăn.
Cái gì phải khá mà mình nghĩa, mình phải bạn ấy đi bàn hẹn.
Và bị người ta lấy dụng mà, và cho dụng đủ đủ đủ đủ đủ đủ đủ đủ đủ.
Vậy cũng rất là mọi người, tại sao nó lại theo người kia,
mà là sao người tìa xong người thêm lo lại theo.
Lột khi chúng ta mong một lạ, chúng ta dụng một lạy đầy, họ sẽ tốt lấy.
Nếu đủ khi thì tất cả tâm lý, lòng vô cuộc tạng,
lời họ đã mục quả chị, chúng ta sẽ phải mất phải nắm.
Thì chúng ta có một cái mong trở,
và khi chúng ta không đặt cái mong trở ở đây,
chúng ta có đổ lỗi dạy đúng ta vào nào phần sẽ họ.
Kể họ nhất để cho chúng ta không phần sẽ.
Tung ta làm việc của trở, lúc cái tâm không mạnh giá không phần sẽ họ.
Mình là một con người bị thua.
A cũng sẽ có những cái dự hạn,
kể họ hành lời nhất là mình không từ bỏ cái đưa chai này.
Mình muốn những lúc xem thêm cái sẹp tỏa vóa vô cắt the first step,
mọi nhanh.